Hollywood hate machine is as unhinged as
ever trying to do anything everything to
smear supporters of the president you
know the smelly Walmart shoppers like me
I love Walmart I love what I think
Costco Walmart they're the best stores
ever look at Debra Messing actress along
with her Will & Grace co-star never seen
the show actually wants to spread a list
of attendees at an upcoming fundraiser
for president Trump apparently as some
sort of intimidation tactic it's getting
pretty sick pretty twisted pretty dark
and now thankfully she's getting
pushback from those who realize how
dangerous this all is and Whoopi
Goldberg earlier today that said this is
nuts
unfortunately Messing didn't stop there
later promoting a sign posted on Twitter
attacking african-americans who support
the President as being quote mentally
ill that was put up by a pastor now the
sad thing is is that oh we have the
lowest unemployment for
african-americans under Donald Trump
than we've ever had and Hispanic
Americans and records numbers of women
in the workplace and youth unemployment
and the best employment situation since
1965 even a category 5 hurricane doesn't
slow down the endless smears HBO
producer David Simon actually tweeting
calling and begging God to destroy mera
Lago that's how sick it's gotten here
with reaction author of this book is
awesome by the way this book amazon.com
bookstores everywhere just released
radicals resistance revenge the left's
plot to remake America and also with us
the host of you know her as Judge Denny
appear along with former Arkansas
governor Fox News contributor Mike
Huckabee Congrats on the books judge I
don't even know how to respond to this
because there's no you cannot talk these
people out of the hate rage and
psychosis you know it's what I talk
about in my book this is another
Hollywood hypocrite who is out for
revenge and is out to resist everything
President Trump has done because Hillary
Clinton didn't get elected when you
think about it Sean who is this woman
who for a living repeats the words that
other people give her to decide whether
or not
someone in Hollywood should work or not
work this is McCarthyism this is as dark
as it gets and too little and they say
that you shouldn't be able to express
your First Amendment rights you
shouldn't vote for Donald Trump that
because you're a trump supporter you're
a racist you're a deplorable you're
whatever isn't there is I know we are we
are smelly Walmart shoppers I know we're
irredeemable deplorable we're and we
cling to our axis and we cling to our
God guns Bibles and religion guilty
guilty governor you're more guilty than
me I try to be I really do I want to be
the most guilty gun in America to
believe in the things that really matter
you know I call it God Guns grits and
gravy which means I live there are
certain things that we embrace
culturally but thank God for Whoopi
Goldberg today who recognized that what
Debra Messing was asking for is a bridge
too far even for the hipsters of
Hollywood when you start carrying around
the list and saying these people support
a political candidate I don't like we're
gonna put you out of business never let
you work in this town again
that is McCarthyism but you looks like
that scene in The Manchurian Candidate
I've got a list yep they sure she's
experienced the baked pies and then she
baked them for the media and they still
didn't believe she baked them my
daughter is a lot nicer than me I
thought probably would've taken the pond
shoved it in the face of some of those
people she simply served one and said
here try it out and see but she's a much
nicer person than her father is
sometimes I never got a pie did you get
a pie judge no I didn't you buried this
you know this reminds me of it it's like
you're saying to people we don't want
you to work if you support Donald Trump
we want you to lose your job like Bill
Maher's saying we want a recession these
people are outright haters and they want
to remake America love out fake news CNN
Humpty Dumpty oh what's it guests Oh
Trump's killed millions more than Mao
Stalin and Hitler stupid and then he's
he complains about Fox all right Thank
You Congressional book